it starts there's something else that
happens outside of fighting yeah as you
as your
popularity get bigger you're not doing
it but it happens to you yeah yeah
you just find yourself in that position
somehow right yeah and i'm happy for it
too because i'm busy all the time before
it would just be fights then down time
and then hope to get a fight again start
training camp now it's like
i have stuff planned as soon as this
fight's over i have other things going
on and
it's good busy is good but like i said
it's just i'm so thin my mind is always
thinking about something non-stop
that's crazy yeah i don't like the other
day i was driving i'm like who the [ __ ]
even is this guy anymore
yeah damn dude [ __ ] well then i
guess i don't know how i got i don't
know if i can uh hit up my bookie and
take my money off of dustin for it
or not but
what's your code dustin
i might have to get in and wager on it
um dude it's pretty crazy to think that
two white guys are now going to the
middle east to fight each other it seems
pretty crazy you know yeah
right um very white
what y'all do for new year's man new
year's we actually got a hotel
room down here in deal for deerfield
beach okay and uh
it's probably about 10 minutes from my
condo just to break it up you know i've
been here since
um let me think
big beginning of november
so training camp just training going to
the back to my condo
going to the gym back to my condo it
just i needed to break it up and okay i
thought new year's was a good idea to
just get a hotel room get out of my
condo
and uh take a morning off did you it was
you and your wife did you go with the
kiddo
yeah me my wife and my daughter oh nice
now and this is personal enough to
answer it and uh
but do you is there like a do you put a
stop on the intimacy of y'all's
relationship if you're heading into a
fight like do you fight
i hear that about fighters i've always
heard that about boxing and stuff they
say it takes your legs away or or
whatnot but dude i've
i've came and knocked people out and
i've not came and knocked people out too
so
i don't really believe in it damn damn
i wonder if i'd rather have a guy who's
already recently
ejaculated yeah knocked me out or a guy
that's full of knocked me out you know
yeah i guess they're all different yeah
yeah
i don't feel it i don't i don't believe
in the and it takes your legs away i
don't think you don't nah i don't think
wow
see that's never really been a thing in
your head where you're like okay when i
was younger i used to i used to you did
yeah dude i was watching fightville and
if you uh if you want to get
amped up for anything if you want to end
up spray painting a building if you want
to fight somebody whatever you want to
do arson
if you go watch fight field dude you
will be freaking pumped for it
um when you watch that do you still
relate to that
to that dustin poirier like it's you're
getting you're growing up
yeah the last time i watched it was a
few years ago but just sitting there why
i feel like it feels like such a
long time ago and i'm such a different
person and
go about fighting and and the thoughts
of preparing for a fight so much
different than
man it really feels like a different
world when i'm watching it i know it's
me i'm watching i remember going through
all the
things in the videos but it's just so
different man so dude they shot it so
well
yeah it took forever to shoot really it
probably took three years to shoot
wow and they have so much fights and
footage they don't even didn't even make
it to it
the problem was um the guy who was
filming it lived in new york with his
family and he would just come down
periodically whenever he he saw a time
in his in his schedule to shoot and he'd
come down for three months here
a month here so it took a really long
time to film the whole thing damn
yeah yeah they shot it i was looking
they shot it through the cage almost as
if they were watching animals
a lot of times like in some way you
understand the the way it looked like
yeah very uh yeah like you said
like animals tribal very tribal yeah
just had like a
i felt like i was watching uh you know
like i remember at lsu they used to have
those videos on mike the tiger all the
time they'd shoot him just kind of going
through the cage you know or doing
something
yeah and uh it just reminded me of that
but and r.i.p to the to the lion
i'm sorry the tiger at the truck stop
right there oh yeah oh yeah did he die
again dude i
i mean one time i think it's a limit but
that's true for us
wow cats have nine lives maybe you're
right that's true but louisiana they got
a camel there did you hear about this
yeah you know what truck stop i'm
talking about tiger truck stop right
right off the uh
the basin bridge oh i don't even know if
i've been there
yeah dude on the chat flyer bridge right
between baton rouge and lafayette yeah i
had the tiger truck stop and they had a
real tiger there
yeah and a camel took his job yeah oh
yeah unbelievable
but the camera recently bit somebody oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well that's a louisiana camper dude
because i think they
they made the camel quit smoking
cigarettes right
he's having some withdrawals um dude
when you watch
uh what's going to be different you
think like heading into this fight what
do you think could be different about it
dude every fight's different whether
it's the same opponent like this is a
rematch or
a completely guy a different guy never
fought before every fight's so different
because i'm in a different place in my
life
in my my you know life's different every
fight so
just trying to learn and uh
be smart moving forward you know not
just in fighting but in life just trying
to move with
with strategy and not emotion man and
that's that's the that's my goal
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
blown